today I have a very special guest on the
Wednesday checkup oh it's the slobbery
bear today we're sharing the story all
about him I'm ready
there are you ready he's ready I want to
start off by telling you right away
little bear was diagnosed with Lyme
disease don't worry he's fine the story
has a happy ending
I just want to tell you about the
process how did Bear get diagnosed with
Lyme disease what I did to treat it I
enrolled bear in a training program to
get him to be hospital certified as a
therapy dog because I think bear is so
doofy and cute he can bring a lot of
happiness and joy to those who are
unfortunately spending some significant
amount of time in the hospital when Bear
came back from training he was due for
his annual physical exam some
vaccinations I also needed a refill of
his heartworm medication this is a
monthly tab that you give to dogs to
prevent parasitic heart disease before
most vets will give the first
prescription of heartworm medication
they'll do a rapid test to confirm that
the dog actively doesn't have that
illness because if they do they need to
get treated for it before getting put on
a preventative dosage what I didn't know
was that when they did the rapid test it
also included a rapid test for Lyme
disease when the vet tech came back they
tell me is that there's positive for
Lyme disease spare is completely
asymptomatic no joint issues no joint
pain no limping
he's happy-go-lucky eating well pooping
while peeing while everything was great
does this probably a false positive but
24 hours later a new vet calls me and
says he is positive for Lyme disease
when I asked some follow-up questions I
wasn't quite happy with the responses I
was getting the vet wasn't certain about
what the test was looking for was an
antigen viral load antibodies he didn't
have much experience with Lyme disease
so I said thank you
I'll make my own decision and I'll
follow up with the office I know when it
comes to Lyme disease in humans it can
be a very controversial topic
I didn't know how controversial it was
in animals Lyme disease is a tick-borne
illness that can be largely prevented by
having proper tick prevention methods in
action bear loves to run around in grass
he grew up in upstate New York which is
a haven for ticks
he has very thick dense brown fur so
it's near impossible to see if he hasn't
tick on him to remove it in treating
Lyme disease in humans I know the
mainstay of treatment is antibiotics
however I didn't want to subject bear to
antibiotics unnecessarily so I decided
to jump into the research and see what I
found when it comes to treating dogs who
weren't showing symptoms to see if it's
even worthwhile to treat them and what I
found really surprised me I'm not a vet
I don't pretend to be a vet
I'm not giving you advice on what you
should do with your dog it's simply me
describing to you what I found in
quality veterinary literature in 2006
the American College of Veterinary
internal medicine published a consensus
of what doctors vet specifically thought
about treating dogs with Lyme business
they did an update to this in 2018 which
is great considering marriage was just
diagnosed with Lyme disease in 2019 this
is what it states verbatim the topic is
still controversial four out of six
doctors do not routinely recommend
treatments for such dogs the majority
events on this internal medicine
committee recommend against treating
dogs with antibiotics that just solely
have a positive Lyme disease test but
don't show any other symptoms and their
urine studies are normal the reason why
they say that it promotes overuse of
antibiotics there's no data proving that
treatment of healthy dogs is associated
with decreased risk of illness very
important lie may not be cleared from
all tissues with treatment reinfection
may commonly occur in dogs and endemic
areas now this consensus is very
important I was able to make the
decision to hold off on treating bear
for Lyme disease however fast forward a
few weeks later bear started limping and
he started getting arthralgias which
means
his joints so I knew was time to start
treating his Lyme disease because he was
starting to get affected by it and
showing symptoms so I went to the vet
picked up the prescription for
doxycycline which is antibiotic of
choice and treating Lyme disease and
it's a very long course it's actually a
30-day course of antibiotics now when
you're giving a dog or even a human such
a long course of antibiotics I think
it's wise to get them on a probiotic at
the same time so you're not completely
destroying the bacteria that's found in
our gut or in the animal's gut and Bayer
did actually really well with the
doxycycline he didn't have any side
effects I was happy that I was able to
get him treatment but not unnecessary
treatment it's always good to become
more informed on the illness that you or
your animals being diagnosed with and
then bring that information to the
doctor or to another doctor for a second
opinion it's been two months since we
finished antibiotics bears doing great
he's happy we're back in training mode
yes and we can open some packages on
camera for a mail time segment what do
you think beer should we do it should we
do mail time doesn't this face look like
a face that wants to do mail time all
right bear so we'd open some packages
and I promise I'll give you whatever was
yours okay it's a letter and a little
bit a little hard badge look at that
look how cute bear that's for you to eat
thank you so much someone from the UK
bear this is the one with your name on
it are you ready oh it's a hide the
hedgehog game here catch
all right go play with your headshot
okay thank you for the Hedgehog bear
loves I think your old face gonna doctor
I want you to pause the camera dad
please a few moments later look this is
my own therapy dog
it is a connoisseur tickets ooh some
green tea matcha I'm not gonna even try
to pronounce that
hey dr. Mike I'm happy to share our love
of tea with you hopefully these are new
additions to your cupboard wow that's so
cool I'm excited to try these if you
enjoyed this video with bear on Lyme
disease drop it down below in the
comments but more importantly if you
want a video on Lyme disease for humans
drop down below in the comments cuz I
actually want to do a video on Lyme
disease and talk about some of the
misinformation that's out there and if
you want to watch a fun and interesting
video at the same time click here and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]